l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur
l'avenir institutionnel politique et
économique de la nouvelle calédonie dans
la perspective du terme du processus
défini par l'accord de nouméa du 5 mai
1998 à la demande du groupe l'est
républicain
je vais d'abord donné la parole à
l'orateur du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat puis ensuite l'ensemble orateurs
puis enfin ou ministre pour la réponse
je vais donc donner la parole à notre
collègue pierre frogier au nom du groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez la parole vous chers collègues
ce président je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
alors que s'ouvre ce débat je pense à
mes compatriotes qui nous écoutent sur
cette terre de nouvelle-calédonie perdu
dans le pacifique
et si lointaine de paris les uns sont à
la recherche d'un chemin vers
l'indépendance
les autres ont choisi depuis longtemps
celui de la france mais tous poursuivent
leur marche dans les ténèbres en se
cognant contre les murs et maintenant
que fait-on
c'est la question que j'entends vous
posez une président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues mais malheureusement
je ne suis pas certain que les réponses
abondent alors que l'accord de nouméa
est devenu un accord anciens dont
l'esprit est moribond et la lettre sans
espoir personne ne sait comment on en
sort
personne ne sait ce qui va se passer
mais vous comprendrez que cette
situation génère une profonde et
légitime inquiétude pour une population
qui ressent l'impasse dans laquelle elle
a été menée et cet envoi se double d'une
incompréhension pour une partie d'entre
elles
à deux reprises déjà elle a exprimé sans
ambiguïté sa volonté de rester française
et ne comprend pas la désinvolture voire
l'indifférence des plus hautes autorités
de l'état
comme si la revendication d'indépendance
harry plus de légitimité que le combat
qu'elle mène pour rester française et
pourtant depuis trente ans la nouvelle
calédonie est engagé dans un processus
exemplaire
après les violents affrontements des
années 80 qui nous ont conduit à une
quasi guerre civile
nous avons choisi le chemin de la paix
et de la réconciliation
en 1988 la signature des accords de
matignon scellé par la poignée de main
jacques lafleur et jean marie tjibaou a
mis un terme à l' escalade de la
violence
dix ans plus tard ces accords ont trouvé
leur prolongement dans l'élaboration
d'une solution consensuelle
qui s'est traduite par la signature de
l'accord de nouméa
mais l'accord de nouméa que nous avons
signés dans l'urgence était inachevée
incomplet et imparfait ou peut-être
n'avions nous pas suffisamment
conscience que ce processus était
fragile délicat et qu'il nécessitait
pour s'épanouir confiance sérénité et
une vraie sincérité en dehors de toute
arrière pensée notamment électoralistes
je fais le constat aujourd'hui devant
vous que l'accord de nouméa était un
acte manqué il a été dénaturée dès 2007
avec le celle du corps électoral pour
les élections provinciales qui a
justifié par la suite toutes les
revendications
toutes les surenchères des
indépendantistes il a été géré de
manière partisane par tout ce qui est
trouvé leur intérêt il a été confisqué
quand on a voulu faire prévaloir le
texte de l'accord sur son esprit au lieu
de le faire vivre
au lieu de le laisser s'épanouir et se
transformer on l'a enfermé monsieur le
ministre dans une formule coupable
l'accord tout l'accord rien que l'accord
qui empêchait toute évolution
pendant des années j'ai proposé de
rechercher cette sortie harmonieuse de
l'accord cette nouvelle solution
consensus ce nouveau compromis qui
aurait consisté aurait constitué la
logique et cohérent de suite de ce que
nous vivons depuis 30 ans elle serait
venue compléter cet accord imparfait
mais je n'ai été entendu ni de ma
famille politique ni les
indépendantistes ni de l'état et
aujourd'hui nous retrouvons dans une
impasse faute d'être parvenus à un
nouvel accord nous sommes réduits à
l'affrontement sans fin de conviction en
conciliant j'avais aussi la conviction
que devions faire l'économie de ces
référendums mortifère qui ne pouvait que
raviver les tensions
les divisions des affrontements à deux
reprises déjà en 2018 en 2020
nous sommes retrouvés face à face mais
c'était dingue c'est un exercice inutile
puisque qu'aucun des deux camps aucun
des deux camps ne se soumettra jamais
aux convictions de l'autre et que quel
que soit le résultat
nos convictions et celle des
indépendantistes ne varieront pas c'est
aussi un exercice dangereux nous qui
étions des partenaires nous sommes
redevenus des adversaires comme si nous
n'avions pas travailler ni gérer
ensemble comme si nous n'avions pas
porter une ambition commune
ces référendums à répétition sont
devenus un engrenage infernal qui
anéantit toute capacité de dialogue je
retiens néanmoins deux enseignements de
ces consultations
le premier c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité pour l'indépendance le second
c'est une triple fracture politique
identitaire et géographique des
électeurs du sud sont massivement
favorables au maintien de la qualité
dans la france des électeurs du nord et
des îles sont massivement favorables à
l'indépendance
nous devons sans concession regarder
cette réalité en face même si elle
bouscule nos certitudes et nos ambitions
malgré les efforts de rééquilibrage
financier et les initiatives économiques
culturelles sociales
nous n'avons pas progressé dans la
construction d'une communauté de destin
les indépendantistes sont et resteront
farouchement indépendantistes et nous
nous sommes et nous resterons
indéfectiblement attachée au maintien de
la calédonie dans la france parce que
chacun de nous reste et restera
intimement attaché à son identité
ces référendums malheureusement or ont
enfermé la vie politique locale dans une
logique d'affrontement l'identitaire
à l'évidence ce que nous avions imaginé
il y a 20 ans et dépasser la réalité
c'est que la nouvelle calédonie est une
terre aux identités multiples où chacun
doit pouvoir développer ses atouts dans
une relation saine stable et pérenne car
la recherche à tout prix de convergence
factice nous a conduit à des confusions
néfastes
la réalité c'est que nous avons un défi
à relever apprendre à savoir vivre
ensemble assumer nos différences pour
rendre notre collectivité humaine plus
forte s'entendre sur nos divergences
pour en limiter les effets et je crois
que nous en sommes capables
alors ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'après avoir négocié deux accords nous
soyons capables aujourd'hui et pour
demain de négocier un désaccord au delà
de la formule qui peut sembler être un
bel oxymore négocier un désaccord c'est
l'assurance d'une coexistence apaisée
dans le respect de nos identités une
différence il ne se jase
il ne s'agit pas de se séparer il ne
s'agit pas de se tourner le dos mais de
s'entendre sur nos divergences afin d'en
limiter les effets de reconnaître ce que
nous partageons accepter ce qui nous
sépare et sur ses bases
organiser notre avenir monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
permettez-moi de tracé de vendre ou les
grandes lignes de cette solution qui
permettra j'espère à la calédonie
d'inventer son avenir est assez pour lui
et à ses populations de vivre
durablement avec concilier deux
principes le premier
la nécessité d'avoir cette paire en
partage le second de réaffirmer la
prééminence de la collectivité
provincial quand je dis qu'il faut avoir
cette terre de calédonie en partage je
pense à cette nuit interminable de juin
1988 alors que nous posions les
principes fondateurs des accords de
matignon
lesquels en partageant le territoire en
trois provinces ont permis le retour de
la paix civile et personnes jusqu'à
aujourd'hui n'a engagé deux procès en
partition de la nouvelle calédonie ni
contre michel regard ni contre
jean-marie tjibaou nique entre jacques
lafleur
c'est donc sur cette base retrouvé que
je propose d'unifier en harmonisant les
contraires au lieu dit ni faut remiser
en écrasant les différences
le coeur de cette proposition c'est de
redonner toute sa place dans la
collectivité provincial conséquence la
collectivité de la nouvelle-calédonie
sera composée de trois provinces dotée
de la compétence de principes
garantissant les différentes identités
de la nouvelle calédonie les communes
seront des collectivités des provinces
certaines compétences pourront leur être
déléguées chaque province sera doté de
son conseil coutumier qu'alain composé
de représentants des chefferies des
aires coutumières de son ressort mais
surtout chaque assemblée de province
sera élu selon son propre régime
électoral afin que nul ne soit exclu
l'état continuera à assurer toutes les
compétences régaliennes défense justice
ordre public monnaies affaires
étrangères mais les provinces pourront
partager certaines prérogatives de
l'état en accord avec lui pour assurer
la gouvernance de la collectivité
nouvelle calédonie pour éviter de tomber
dans les travers et les lourdeurs de ce
gouvernement collégial mise en place par
l'accord de merde je propose la
constitution d'un collège médiateurs
composé du représentant de l'état
évidemment des représentants des
assemblées province son président
représentera la nouvelle calédonie en
toutes circonstances cette gouvernance
c'est un processus de coordination des
provinces et de l'état en vue
d'atteindre des objectifs définis et
discuter collectivement mais c'est aussi
un mode d'organisation qui impliquera
des négociations permanentes sur un pied
d'égalité entre les provinces
il ne s'agira plus de dicter d'en haut
des priorités et de se contenter de
réguler les d'arbitré afin d'assurer le
libre a pas le libre épanouissement des
provinces il s'agira d'une répartition
plus horizontale du pouvoir le savoir
vivre ensemble nécessitera des règles
communes
mais au lieu d'être imposées d'en haut
les mesures prises résulteront d'un
processus d'élaboration collective
guidé par la recherche de réponses aux
défis communs conformément à des valeurs
contenues dans une charte
cette charte définira un engagement de
valeurs partagées de droit de liberté
garantie par le conseil d'état le
conseil constitutionnel de la république
exprimera par ailleurs l'adaptation du
droit civil aux identités plurielles de
la nouvelle calédonie concernant les
personnes la famille
les rapports entre les personnes et
leurs rapports ou sociale cette solution
institutionnelle sera sera bien sûr
soumise à l'approbation des populations
intéressées
monsieur le ministre j'ai entamé mon
propos en évoquant le sort de mes
compatriotes
il continue de cheminer dans l'éternel
ils le doivent
il devrait en grande partie à cet état à
cet état que vous incarnez aujourd'hui
cet état qui hésitent qui hésitent
encore qui hésite toujours entre se
débarrasser de la question quel est de
nien ou traiter la question et les
données se débarrassait la question
calédonienne s'est laissé entendre que
l'indépendance en association ou en
partenariat reste possible à la
condition bien sûr que les intérêts
économiques et militaires de l'état
soient garantis se débarrasser la
question calédoniennes
c'est malheureusement abandonné à son
sort toute cette population est alimenté
les tensions traiter la question
calédoniennes c'est apporter une
solution d'aujourd'hui une solution
d'aujourd'hui un vieux problème ce n'est
pas réparé le passé c'est réussir à
conjuguer respect de la démocratie
locale respect des identités respect des
différences et intérêts de la france
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je m'adresse à vous car la
nouvelle calédonie ne peut plus attendre
elle a besoin de développer un autre
visage elle a besoin que sans attendre
une main nue soit tendu en incarnant la
bonne volonté de la république à
l'endroit de tous les calédoniens en
apportant sa culture de la sagesse à une
question territoriale qui peut avoir des
conséquences importantes y compris dans
d'autres territoires ultramarins notre
haute assemblée pourrait incarner cet
espoir et permettent à la nouvelle
calédonie
de devenir un laboratoire de
l'adaptation républicaine aux réalités
des territoires et de vivre ses
différences sereinement en favorisant
par l'intelligence collective
la co construction d'une solution
d'aujourd'hui nous passerions d'une
logique de centralisation plus de
décentralisation à une logique de
regroupement des territoires ce
président je veux conclure en vous
priant d'avoir rampait le seul le sort
de ce jeune indépendantiste par
solidarité un des identitaires celui de
son ami loyalistes à l'identité
culturelle si différentes
je vous demande pour de vous engager
afin de les libérer de la peur de
l'autre leur permettre d'être français
enfants en valorisant respectant leurs
différences et en inscrivant leur avenir
dans une appartenance commune je vous
remercie
merci votre collègue
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de notre débat je vais
donner la parole aux présidents
guillaume gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire une
cinq minutes la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
remercie d'abord mais mes collègues du
groupe a l'air d'avoir proposé ce débat
et je remercie aussi l'initiative du
président larcher d'un groupe de travail
sénatorial et trans partisan sur la
question calédonienne question d'une
brûlante actualité qui continuera à
l'être ces prochaines années alors que
nous arrivons au terme du processus de
nouméa le caillou à occuper occupe et
occupera votre gouvernement comme aucun
autre 21ème siècle il sera également
l'un des premiers gros dossiers du
gouvernement qui sortira des urnes en
la demande de ce troisième référendum
d'autodétermination intervient dans une
situation économique dégradée dans une
situation politique fragmenté et dans
l'utilisation social toujours plus
conflictuel cela n'a rien d'étonnant
alors que l'on s'approche de la fin d'un
processus entamé il ya plus de 30 ans et
dont les six représentent un vide
politique
une feuille presque blanche qui reste à
écrire la situation particulièrement
tendue est bloquée de l'hiver a
néanmoins connu une légère accalmie et
je salue notamment l'intervention
bienvenue de l'état qui a favorisé une
solution de reprise du complexe minier
vale solution plutôt intéressante avec
un capital majoritairement détenue par
les collectivités calédonienne un pet un
partenariat avec testa pour stabiliser
les débouchés économiques et ambitieux
projet sur le papier du moins de
préservation de l'environnement
rappelons que ce site accueille la plus
grosse usine mondiale d'acide sulfurique
dans une zone riche d'une biodiversité
exceptionnelle
les écologistes vous vous en douterez
seront particulièrement exigeant sur ce
dernier point
ce week-end c'est la paralysie politique
qui durait depuis la mi-février qui
semble trouver une issue avec le
compromis qui s'esquisse entre les
formations indépendantistes à la tête du
gouvernement de l'île entre temps la
demande d'un troisième référendum à
l'automne 2022 a été effectué vous avez
invité tout
les formations politiques calédoniennes
à paris à la fin du mois pour envisager
ce référendum et les conséquences des
deux scénarii dans lequel pourrait
s'engager
la nouvelle calédonie à l'issue de ce
scrutin votre démarche tout semble être
la bonne néamoins ne sera utile que si
toutes les forces politiques sont
effectivement présente aussi nous paraît
essentiel de convaincre les partis
indépendantistes de faire le déplacement
en affinant rapidement votre programme
de travail et aux besoins en envoyant un
émissaire gouvernementale sur l'île pour
caler les choses sans cela vous ne
parviendrez pas à tenir votre promesse
d'un travail consiste en sont les
conséquences du oui et celle du non un
travail à même d'éclairer le débat
référendaire
les électrices et des électeurs mais
aussi tout le pays le kali drian et le
calendrier pardon étant ce qu'il est
vous ne pourrez pas vous engager sur une
gestion de l'après référendum qui ne
sera peut-être pas du ressort de
l'actuel exécutif
nous vous demandons donc de construire
en amont avec toutes les forces
politiques nationales
le compromis politique le plus large
possible sur que sera l'attitude de la
france pour soutenir et favoriser en cas
de victoire du non
l'émancipation du peuple kanak seul à
même d'apaiser les tensions
pour accompagner en cas de victoire du
oui l'indépendance autant qu'il le
faudra et dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
c'est la seule manière d'apporter des
perspectives relativement stable aux
calédoniens pour un débat transparent
qui ne court pas le risque d'un
spectaculaire volte face à la fin du
printemps 2022
quel que soit le choix du peuple
calédonien il n'effacera pas l'héritage
colonial de liddes et son corollaire de
division d' inégalités socio-économiques
inacceptable et 2 confie que tu alité
quel que soit ce choix il ne réglera pas
la trop forte dépendance de l'île à
l'extraction du nickel et à ses très
graves conséquences écologiques comme
social quel que soit ce choix il ne fera
pas disparaître l'intérêt presque
prédateurs parfois de la france pour
lille quel que soit quelques sauts pour
les ressources que ce soit pardon pour
les ressources minières ou pour
l'intérêt géostratégique de sa présence
dans le pacifique la dépendance envers
la métropole qui s'est construite depuis
plus d'un siècle
et de toute façon beaucoup trop forte
pour permettre au peuple calédoniens de
disposer librement de lui-même
les destins de la france et de la
nouvelle calédonie resteront liés
quel que soit le choix des urnes mais
pour favoriser autant que possible un
choix autonomes
la france doit apporter des garanties
sur le devenir politique de l'île
quel que soit le scénario choisi
démocratiquement dans 18 mois
alors monsieur le ministre est une tâche
exaltante à laquelle vous vous attelez
contribué à inventer le devenir d'un
territoire et de ses populations pour se
libérer enfin du poids de l'héritage
colonial et pour engager une 30 une
transition sociale économique et
écologique à même de réduire les
inégalités inégalités construire le
vivre ensemble et de préserver un
environnement et une biodiversité
incomparable
merci merci monsieur le président je
vais maintenant appeler notre collègue
michaele que l'hymne que l'i mode au tec
est ok part de mémoire pour le
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant
la parole mon cher collègue sur le
président sur le ministre mes chers
collègues s'est humblement en tant que
sénateur de gilles wallis et futuna
connaissant le tiraillement entre deux
cultures que je me tiens devant vous
aujourd'hui
c'est également en tant qu'enseignant
france est profondément ancré dans des
traditions et les coutumes de mai il que
je prends la parole pour témoigner comme
voisin un spectateur privilégié de
l'histoire de la nouvelle calédonie
surnommé le caillou cette occasion je
salue chaleureusement au passage la
communauté wallisienne et futunienne de
nouvelle calédonie lalbenque et jolie
entre dans la dernière phase d'un
processus inédit
ce processus a été une source
exceptionnelle d'optimisme il a démontré
la capacité des femmes et des hommes à
trouver au sein de la république
française des solutions novatrices pour
répondre aux défis qui s'imposent a
toutefois eu cette source se tarit à
mesure que se rapproche le prochain
référendum
mes chers collègues ne nous voilons pas
la face sur la situation de la nouvelle
khedri
ce territoire est divisée entre deux
communautés
si elle s'accepte et se respectent
désormais et continue toutefois de
nourrir des ambitions antagonistes pour
leur avenir les inégalités ils sont
encore trop forte
d'autant qu'elle s'inscrive dans une
réalité ethnique qui les rend révoltante
et insoutenable d'un côté les
indépendantistes militant pour la
communauté kanak dont chacun sait ici
les souffrances et les humiliations
qu'elle a subies dans son histoire
recouvre une dignité et une légitimité
existentielle qui lui sont dus avec
comme horizon l'accession de lalbenque
et de vie à son indépendance
de l'autre les loyalistes attaché aux
valeurs françaises et à l'accompagnement
de l'état
aspyr a évolué
et en restant au sein de la république
cette division est partagée de manière
proportionnelle par l'ensemble des
différentes communautés vivant sur le
caillou les deux premiers référendum en
sont le reflet par deux fois déjà les
calédoniens les calédoniennes ont prouvé
leur capacité à se réinventer en faisant
le pari sur l'intelligence collective au
détriment de l'affrontement
ceci a été symbolisée par la poignée de
main historique entre jean marie tjibaou
et jacques lafleur les calédoniens
seront donc bientôt amener une fois
encore à décider de leur avenir
institutionnel au nom des français que
nous représentons je veux leur dire
combien nous souhaitons qu'ils fassent
le choix du dialogue et de la sagesse et
chers collègues en nouvelle calédonie
est à l'orée d'une nouvelle période de
son histoire est fait cependant face à
d'importants défis
en tant qu'île du pacifique elle sera
aux premières loges des conséquences du
réchauffement climatique comme
l'ensemble des outre-mer menacés par la
montée des eaux
elle doit également composer avec des
perspectives économiques moroses
l'économie calédonienne reste dépendante
d'un or vert et du sinn non rentables
qui n'ont pas tenu leurs promesses de
diversification malgré l'intervention de
l'état
niché au coeur de la kz1 d'eau pacifique
sur lequel le président emmanuel macron
a eu raison de porter un regard attentif
la nouvelle calédonie attise les
convoitises ces ressources minières et
halieutiques aiguise l'appétit l'appétit
l'influencent dont l'intérêt pour les
droits humains et écologiques et bien
moins marqué que celui de la france
comme la nouvelle calédonie comment la
nouvelle clinique compte-t-elle répondre
à tous ces défis
comment compte-t-elle financer la
diversification de son économie comment
compte-t-elle assuré le rééquilibrage
économique et social comment
compte-t-elle résister à la présence
croissante d'influencés étrangères
enfin quelle sera la stratégie
géopolitique de la france dans la région
autant de problématiques qui seront au
centre des discussions dans les semaines
à venir
grâce à l'implication du ministre le
corps nu que je salue il est urgent
d'échanger sur les conséquences du oui
et du non c'était un impératif absolu
mais la principale question mes chers
collègues est la suivante quelle est la
position de l'état français dans ce
débat si l'avenir de la nouvelle
calédonie ne se décidera pas dans les
hémicycles métropolitain il est
indispensable que l'état et la
représentation nationale prennent toute
leur place dans ce débat
en engageant l'avenir des calédoniens le
gouvernement engage également celui des
français je saisis donc l'occasion qui
m'est donnée ici pour remercier le
président larcher d'avoir initié cet
échange porteur d'espoir je salue
également au passage mes amis sénateurs
cali de liens ce pire ce projet et
monsieur gérard adja monsieur le
ministre les calédoniens sont inquiets à
quelques mois du prochain référendum
aucun accord n'a été trouvé aucune
assurance des données aux calédoniens
qu'ils soient pour ou contre
l'indépendance
pour ma part j'ai vite les leaders et
dirigeants calédoniens à une
concertation collective à penser de
nouvelles perspectives et des garanties
rassurant la population dans son
ensemble le débat qu'elle ait de lien
interroge tous les ultramarins
mais également chaque français il soumet
à notre réflexion
l'évolution des rapports que nous
collectivités ultramarines pouvons
entretenir avec la métropole
une relation qui se doit d'être apaisées
au sein de laquelle la place et les
coutumes de chacun sont respectées
cette relation doit aussi être pérenne
pour lever le voile de l'incertitude et
permettre à tous de se projeter vers un
destin commun elle offre enfin un autre
jeunesse les moyens de réussir à relever
les nombreux défis qu'elle devra
affronter cette jeunesse nous écoute à
nouméa à koné ah ouais mais aussi à
manta hutus à saint denis
pointe à pitre ou à papeete elles
portent nos espoirs
même dans des situations compliquées
comme quand elle doit venir étudier en
métropole mais cette jeunesse
d'abondantes fois elle nous regarde avec
insistance
aujourd'hui elle attend donc tous les
calédoniens que ses représentants et
l'état soient claires sur l'avenir sur
l'avenir que nous lui préparons pour
cela nous devons dire les choses sur le
ministre seul président mes chers
collègues le gouvernement doit rassurer
les clés de lien et les français
les silences de cet horizon à certains
poussent chacun dans ses derniers
retranchements et creuse le lit d'une
inquiétude et d'une colère dont on sait
qu'elle sera qu'elles seront à l'origine
de tragiques événements il est de notre
responsabilité de faire maintenir le
dialogue entre les différentes
composantes calédonienne afin que la
dernière consultation aboutissent à un
avenir radieux et prometteur pour
l'ensemble des calédoniens au leti
wenzhou
je vous remercie clé si chers collègues
je vais donner la parole va t'on
président jean claude requier pour le
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen avait la parole monsieur le
président le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 24
septembre 1953 à l'occasion du
centenaire de la présence française
nouvelle calédonie le ministre de la
france d'outré mer de l'époque louis
jacquinot souligné que si un siècle plus
tard la phrase adopté le nouvel écrin
doni en affirmant des droits sur une
terre ils savaient désormais que ces
droits comporte également des devoirs
c'est un des ses devoirs que nous sommes
d'autant plus confrontés que pour notre
part nous estimons que la nouvelle
calédonie a pleinement sa place dans la
république
aujourd'hui l'espoir de régime et
pérenniser de plus en plus proche
hittistes poursuivre avec la france ou
vers l'indépendance
cela poursuit ce qu'avait engagée à 30
ans
j'aimerais qui va ou jacques lafleur et
qui doit aller à son terme
nous avons le lien entre la france et
nouvelle calédonie est le fruit d'une
histoire coloniale souvent présentes et
d'un processus de décolonisation
laborieux depuis l'accord de nouméa il
qu'au troisième référendum qui pourrait
avoir lieu d'ici 2022
nous demeurons à la recherche d'un
équilibre ce territoire aux antipodes la
métropole les enjeux politiques et
sociaux
il somme particulièrement complexe et
justifie pleinement que des boisses a
consacré à ces questions pour lesquelles
chacun d'eux sort faire preuve de
prudence de tempérance d'autant que
l'enchère des clios traduit également
par des aspects précis et délicat
notamment d'un point de vue juridique
ça me là j'aimerais aller aucun
spécifique celui de l'application
nouvelle calédonie de régis le droit
inhérent symathisants l'existence de
deux populations celles et autonome
kanaté celles qui résultent du processus
connus comme nos savoirs une partie du
toit callac originel poursuit d'être
appliquées notamment par le truchement
du lot statut civil coutumier et c'est
de ce point de vue là qualys un système
juridique est nominatif pose des
difficultés concrètes
la loi organique du 10 novembre 1999
relative à noël canonique a suivi
l'accord global est bienvenu venu
organiser l'articulation des droits
coutumiers et du droit commun il n'en
reste pas moins que ces dispositions ne
raisonne pas pleinement les questions
pratiques qui se posent aux autorités
coutumières
alors qu'en vérité est-elle quelqu'un
que la rigueur législations permettent
mal aux juridictions de faire face à ce
qu'on peut qualifier une crise le jury
dix sites et de la coutume ou à londres
l'une des problématiques sortie des
accords de nouméa en bus des enjeux
politiques institutionnelles le soir
indépendance lui maintiennent doit aussi
tenir compte des dimensions
juridiquement concrètes
quel que soit associant tenu que des
pratiques du droit commun du droit
coutumier et de 6 kg a déjà été acquis
dans leurs articulations certaines
avancées ont déjà pu avoir lieu ainsi le
sénat coutumier ne nous éclaire doni
adopter en 2011
une délibération sur le cadre de
résolution des conflits à mieux
coutumier qui vise à appliquer avant que
le congrès ne dépasse le terrain
fumier pour gagner le terrain judiciaire
et pénal il n'y reste néamoins du chemin
à parcourir pour aboutir à un système
pérenne et qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
choisis qui sont choisis la voie du
maintien
ou celle de l'indépendance par ailleurs
aussi essentiel soit elle était question
de l'indépendance comme parfois mettre
un voile sur d'autres difficultés que
rencontrent les colonies je pense par
exemple à certaines pratiques laterrière
liés aux infrastructures dire aux
routiers qui ont souffert souffre
toujours ni passage de la dépression
tropicale lucas au mois de février
dernier
depuis plusieurs mois des autres furent
barré ou endommagées compliquant
signifie significativement la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens essais
techniques sont débordés une peine
encore à répondre à toutes les demandes
je n'évoque pas ses questions par goût
de la rigueur parce que ça est
susceptible d'affecter la qualité du
débat démocratique engagé à mener et qui
devrait se poursuivre encore bien
souligné d'ailleurs que senna va pas
nous toute sa place dans le processus
nous doit rester mobilisée pour nous
prononcer sur l'évolution nous allons
les colonies après les choses que nous
connaissons au foie au fond le choix
d'indépendance ou du maintien de la
phrase ne suffira pas à résoudre ses
difficultés structurelles économiques
les renverra les référendums ne répare
pas les routes et ponts se rendent aux
urnes ainsi pas à athènes difficulté
aussi j'ai conduire dans l'intervention
par le souhait que la france tout en
respectant l'expression démocratique
dans lequel gouvernement est pleinement
investi ce dont je me félicite
poursuivre son soutien en nouvelle
calédonie afin que cette dernière
accepte encore davantage de sérénité
tant politique économique ou social
merci monsieur le président je vais
donner la parole maintenant à madame la
présidente du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologisme adam
eliane assassi vous avez la parole
madame la présidente
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues l'histoire de la
nouvelle calédonie est marqué par des
épisodes douloureux par des tensions qui
ont abouti aux événements comme on dit
des années 80 quasi guerre civile qui a
fait couler le sang entre partisans et
opposants à l'indépendance
c'est dans ce contexte de violences
qu'ont été signés les accords de
matignon 88 pour puis l'accord de nouméa
en 98 à strictement parler nous arrivons
au terme du processus référendaire
puisque les indépendantistes du congrès
ont demandé la tenue du troisième
référendum d'ici octobre 2022
la préparation de ce dernier référendum
ne peut se limiter à la seule réponse
binaire dans wii ou d'un non à
l'indépendance
nous respecterons le résultat car nous
sommes particulièrement attachés autres
au droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes et la réponse quelle qu'elle
soit ne mettra pas fin aux tensions
le précédent référendum a été l'occasion
d'une campagne très violente entre
indépendantistes et loyalistes
ces derniers ont réservé récemment perdu
le contrôle du gouvernement alors qu'ils
y étaient majoritaires depuis 98 le
dialogue engagé par l'état entre
l'ensemble des interlocuteurs est
essentiel car quoi qu'il arrive il doit
faire société
les conflits politiques créent des
situations de blocage institutionnel
comme nous le voyons avec la difficulté
pour le nouveau gouvernement calédonien
d'élire son président lavaur référendum
implique donc une large campagne
d'information et de concertation
d'une part explicité à chaque citoyenne
et à chaque citoyen calédonien les
enjeux liés à ce référendum en matière
fiscale en matière agricole industrielle
sur la citoyenneté et les questions
régaliennes d'autres pas pour recueillir
leurs avis tout en conservant sa
neutralité
l'état a ici un rôle à jouer pour m'être
fait pour mettre ces informations à
disposition
monsieur le ministre où en est-on dans
les consultations lancées au local selon
l'économiste olivier sudrie si la
nouvelle calédonie a était un pays
indépendant
elle serait la deuxième nation la plus
inégalitaire de l' ocde l'héritage
colonial structure encore la société
calédonienne avec des disparités
ethnique importante malgré la division
par deux des inégalités entre kanaks et
caldoches en 20 ans le taux de pauvreté
de la province nord demeure de 35%
contre eux demeurent de 35 % contre 9 %
au sud
il va jusqu'à 50 2% dans les îles
loyauté ou les kanak sont encore plus
présents que dans le nord les 10% de la
population la plus aisée à un niveau de
vie 8 fois plus élevés que les 10% les
plus modestes
ces clivages nourrissent la volonté
d'indépendance
mais on ne peut affirmer que celle ci
permettrait une réduction des inégalités
si le oui l'emporté il nous faudra
accompagner les calédoniens dans leur
transition vers l'indépendance et
développer la coopération afin de
s'assurer que la dépendance actuelle à
la métropole de creuse les inégalités
si le don l'emportent de nouveaux outils
devront permettre de favoriser un
développement égalitaire de l'archipel
l'état n'a pas su préserver des
identités des différentes populations
qui le composent
ni faire cesser les discriminations
raciales ou reconnaître à leur hauteur
la place des populations kanakes ses
lacunes ont créé des incompréhensions et
nourrissent des distensions le prochain
référendum ni mettra pas fin la
démocratie parlera vous écouteront le
choix des calédoniens
mais comment voir une destinée commune
avec de telles inégalités économiques et
sociales
le statut juridique n'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga contrairement à l'objectif de
faire fonctionner société pluriethnique
et pluriculturelle l'hexagone et la
nouvelle calédonie sont liés par une
douloureuse histoire que l'archipel
demeure dans notre république ou à ses
côtés
l'état ne peut se déresponsabiliser à
cela s'ajoutent des enjeux en termes
d'autonomie économique l'archipel
bénéficiant de ressources qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui pas mises à profit comme sa
faune et sa flore marines
la dépendance à l'industrie du nickel
qui emploie un salarié du privé sur
quatre dont 60 % d'ouvriers a montré ses
limites comme l'a prouvé la vente de
l'ensemble de l'entreprise valent des
impératifs économiques mais aussi
environnementaux implique une dé
diversification de l'économie
calédonienne enfin des aspects
géopolitiques vient de se lier à ces
questions puisque l'archipel est
convoité à l'international alors
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur président j'aimerais eux n'ont
pas clore mes ouvrir mon intervention
par ces mots de louise-michel envoyé au
bagne en nouvelle calédonie en 1873 pour
avoir été communarde elle disait chacun
cherche sa route
nous cherchons la nôtre et nous pensons
que le jour où le règne de la liberté de
l'égalité sera arrivé le genre humain
sera heureux merci wallemme le pays dont
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue gérard poadja pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
[Applaudissements]
la parole chers collègues monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues s'arrose ils étaient 115 kanak
exhibé lors de l'exposition universelle
de 1900 30 heures au parc de vincennes
on les avait exposé à côté de crocodiles
parce que les sauvages
je vais être à côté des bêtes sauvages
la brochure disait venez voir les kanaks
car c'est une race qui va bientôt
disparaître
seul il a pris une balle seul sur la
pauvreté de ses parents c'est une belle
journée de janvier 1980 il avait 17 ans
et la mort a frappé de manière aveugle
il rappelé yves et je t'appelais james
aussi et je t'appelais tant d'autres
pourquoi 4 ils étaient 4 4 sous le
soleil de fayaoué 4 loin de la terre
natale dans la brigade
quand le temps s'arrête à c'était deux
jours avant le premier tour des
élections présidentielles de 1988
2il gt2 et je n'ai pas la levée de deuil
un abri de a serré les mains a salué les
autorités coutumières et les familles
quand ils ont été abattus par un des
leurs il s'appelait jean marie et yéyé
c'était un 4 mai
si je raconte cette histoire c'est parce
que c'est la mienne celle d'un kanak
originaire de la tribu du rwanda d'où le
dollar continue à oisy de nos vies en
province nord
si je raconte cette histoire c'est parce
que c'est un seul de mon peuple je perds
le calédonien
si je rapporte cette histoire c'est
parce que c'est la nôtre celle de la
france
ces 170 ans d'une histoire nous nous
sommes les héritiers jeu prenant sur ces
mots avec une gravité à la veille d'un
double anniversaire a hautement
symbolique celui de la chaux de la
grotte de gossanah à ouvéa et de la
signature de l'accord de nouméa
mes chers collègues nous ne vivons pas
sur une page blanche au moment où le
peuple calédoniens seront appelés à
décider pour la troisième fois en quatre
ans
si la nouvelle calédonie doit devenir un
de vos notes ou demeurer au sein de la
république française
pourtant je crois plus que jamais au
destin commun entre la france et la
nouvelle calédonie un destin commun
nourri par une histoire une langue une
école et des valeurs mais aussi par
trente ans de souveraineté partagée
je crois plus que jamais au destin
commun du peuple calédonien un peuple
pas raisonner en lui parler sont mêlés
une culture métissée et de mémoire
contre la c mais aussi par une
gouvernance partagée des institutions du
pays entre indépendantistes et non un
terroriste c'est parce que ce destin
commun sont au coeur de notre histoire
que je ne veux pas d'un troisième
référendum d'inr comment une moitié de
la population du pays
pourrait-elle imposer son choix à
l'autre moitié quand on connaît notre
histoire
c'est pourquoi nous proposons de ce type
dut substituer à cette troisième
consultation à référendum de
rassemblement mensuel à référendum de
rassemblement c'est admettre avoir les
indépendantistes que l'indépendance
n'est pas une baguette magique
face aux inégalités à l'échec scolaire
et à la délinquance
tu me andreu société construira
référendum de rassemblement j'ai accepté
pour les non indépendantistes de
revisiter notre lien à la france un
référendum de rassemblement s'est
conjugué ceux qui nous ont jusqu alors
opposé
la souveraineté et la république ce sont
ces deux essence que pour nous devons
fusionner opposé le nouveau poteau
central de la grande casse du pays
la souveraineté parce qu'elle est
nécessaire en termes de reconnaissance
et de dignité pour les indépendantistes
habré soit 110 ans d'histoire la
république pascal assure le lien entre
toutes les communautés du pays
parce qu'elle nous protège on a en
garantissant notre sécurité à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur de nos
frontières
parce qu'elle nous permet de bénéficier
de l'un des niveaux de vie les plus
élevés de la région pacifique construire
leurs achats dans deux rassemblements
sait conjuguer le oui et le non pour
toucher un nouveau consensus sur un
avenir partagé comme le long des accords
de matignon et de nouméa penser à
l'argent dans des rassemblements c1 pour
suivre la trajectoire de notre
émancipation tout en restant protégé par
la france le dialogue prochain sous
l'autorité du président de la république
pourrait nous offrir cette opportunité
soit nous sommes capables de poser les
bases de ce référendum rassemblement et
son organisation en septembre 2009 22
fait sens car elle nous donne le temps
je suis une alizé un projet d'avenir
partager soit ces échanges sont
infructueux et dans ce cas autre
organisé le troisième référendum vers la
fin de l'année 2000 21 afin d'ouvrir le
plus rapidement possible les discussions
sur la l'abri accords de nouméa
mais attention les discussions après le
troisième référendum sera publiée à il y
aura alors un vainqueur électorale est
invaincue les concessions réciproques
pourquoi suis-je un consensus sans
possible alors troisième référendum
elle sera très difficile voire
impossible après et en cas de non le
droit à l'autodétermination de rats de
traitement de tous
on continue à s'exercer jusqu'à quand
avec quelles conséquences sur ce chemin
certains brandissent désormais comme
solution là par la partition du pays où
ses deux déclinaisons l'hyper
provincialisation et la différenciation
cet apartheid géographie nous conduira à
effacer
soit cinquante ans d'histoire commune
les kanaks avec les kanaks et les autres
avec les autres
et croyez moi beaucoup de ceux qui
aujourd'hui vivent en province nord d'où
je suis originaire sont radicalement
opposés à cette perspective notre
réalité c'est un pays un et indivisible
dans l'accord de nouméa a exclu dès
l'origine tout partition en fonction des
résultats du référendum
notre réalité aujourd'hui c'est un pays
qui n'a pas de frontières le découper
c'est l'entité c'est le ghetto est
qu'autoriser notre avenir c'est de
continuer à conjuguer nos de rêve pour
une même terre et nos noms d'affecter
chaque grève à une terre c'est pour moi
le seul chemin possible pour favoriser
l'émergence d'un pays rassemblés on paie
avec lui-même
on est confiant dans sa destinée vers le
jardin de rassemblement avec tous les
calédoniens jure l'europe radio pas les
miens et vive la france
merci mes chers collègues je m'attends
appelé le président patrick nerfs pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicains je suis le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous avons
dû déjà eu l'occasion de débattre du
devenir de la nouvelle calédonie dans
des circonstances autrement plus
dramatiques
nous pouvons nous féliciter que ce débat
se déroule aujourd'hui dans un contexte
de paix civile
il constitue l'occasion d'évoquer je
remercie le groupe ait l'air le passé
mais surtout l'avenir un lob du
troisième référendum sur leur
indépendance
le passé c'est la colonisation qui a
entraîné un traumatisme durable pour la
population d'origine une histoire qui a
vu les kanaks devenir minoritaires dans
leur propre pays
la nouvelle calédonie jarry encore la
mémoire des révolte écrasée dans le sang
et de luttes parfois instrumentalisée
entre les tribus malgré ses souffrances
indicibles les kanak ont accepté de
reconnaître que les femmes et les hommes
qui se sont installés en nouvelle
calédonie qui ont contribué à son
développement qui ont participé à
l'effort collectif ont sans nul doute
vocation à participer à la détermination
d'un destin commun c'est ce constat qui
figure dans le préambule de l'accord de
nouméa de 98 un accord dans lequel nous
nous inscrivons nine ou sans vous ni
vous sans nous dans le prolongement et
la fidélité aux accords de matignon de
88 tous là dans le même bateau ces
accords mes chers collègues ont
durablement instaurer un esprit de
dialogue entre les signataires on a
parlé de miracle à l'époque à leur
propos mais ils sont surtout le résultat
de la générosité de l'intelligence de la
détermination d'hommes et de femmes dans
un contexte où la violence avait atteint
son paroxysme avec la prise d'otages
d'ouvéa et son issue sanglante
ce fut l'honneur des gouvernements
rocard et jospin mais aussi de jean
marie tjibaou et jacques lafleur ainsi
que celles et ceux qui s'inscrivent dans
leur sillage d'avoir su entendre les
revendications du peuple kanak et les
doutes des autres composantes de la
société calédonienne
ils ont prouvé que l'état n'est pas
seulement autoritaire et répressif mais
qu'il joue d'abord un rôle de
pacification
tout ce qui a été entrepris depuis en
nouvelle calédonie repose sur un idéal
de tolérance et de respect de l'autre
qui permet d'envisager le passage d'un
destin communautaire
et parcellaire à la construction d'un
destin commun et partagé
il s'agit maintenant de rester fidèle à
ses principes de garantir le maintien
des conditions de la concorde et de la
paix mais parce qu'il ya un mais
l'accord de nouméa est temporaire c'est
ainsi qu'il a été imaginé c'est ainsi
qu'il a été voulue l'avenir c'est le
choix des liens nouveaux entre la
nouvelle calédonie et la république
française
la perspective de l'ultime référendum
durcit cela a été dit
les relations entre les forces
politiques et quel que soit le résultat
et nous savons qu'il sera dense et déjà
serré l'état ne pourra pas se dérober
il nous revient d'appréhender les
conséquences concrètes de tout de tous
les scénarios et l'état sans se départir
de son impartialité qui est d'ailleurs
garantie par les accords de matignon
doit s'engager sur la nouvelle calédonie
d'après ce qui doit primer c'est d'avoir
un cheminement est un processus qui
puisse rassembler
l'état devra proposer une solution il
devra dire comment il accompagnera la
nouvelle calédonie dans les voix qu'elle
pourra choisir aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre la voix du gouvernement doit
être plus ferme
dans ce cadre nous ne partageons pas ce
que suggère notre collègue pierre
frogier celui qui pourtant fut l'homme
des deux drapeaux côte à côte
comment peut-on raisonnablement penser
que la solution soit le chacun chez soi
un drapeau au nord un drapeau sud
la différenciation politique que le
sénateur frogier propose rime avec
confédération et vous pourriez nous dire
monsieur le sénateur puisque les
résultats électoraux confiant scrutin
après scrutin que la nouvelle calédonie
est une addition de particularismes
géographiques ethniques alors respectons
les respectons ces différences
organisons la partition politique ce
n'est rien d'autre qu'une partition
territoriale à laquelle ne pouvons pas
adhéré cette idée de provincialisation
consiste en réalité à accroître les
prérogatives des provinces ce qui est
présenté comme une décentralisation est
en fait une division strict du
territoire avec des fortunes économique
particulièrement déséquilibré un tel
projet
est insoutenable impraticable il
aiguisera inexorablement l'acrimonie
entre les deux camps mon groupe n'a pas
de certitude mais il a des convictions
il se pose comme le garant de l'esprit
de nouméa en refusant fermement la
partition et en rappelant que l'héritage
rocard jospin et celui d'hommes et de
femmes qui ont compris que tout était à
redouter si chacun persistait à s'isoler
faisons place mes chers collègues à une
nouvelle imagination et pourquoi pas
imaginer une solution de dialogue et de
compromis qui pourrait être acceptable
en préconisant la pleine souveraineté de
la nouvelle calédonie dans le cadre d'un
partenariat institutionnel avec la
france elle impliquerait ensuite
l'inscription d'un partenariat dans les
constitutions respectives de chaque pays
il s'agit en quelque sorte d'une formule
d'état associé qui a fait ses preuves
par ailleurs dans le monde l'état est un
arbitre mais aussi un partenaire
arbitres parce qu'il doit veiller à
l'application des engagements pris
partenaires parce qu'il ne peut pas
rester spectateur indifférent
il doit accompagner chaque collègue je
laisserai donc ce dernier mot à jean
marie tjibaou homme de paix qui
déclarait tranquillement l'indépendance
c'est la faculté de choisir ses inter
dépendances
je pense que cette phrase pourrait
devenir prophétique
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci monsieur le président et de l'est
maintenant la parole à notre collègue
pierre médevielle et pour le groupe les
indépendants vous avez la parole vous
chers collègues
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues les enjeux liés à la
nouvelle calédonie me sont chers et
familier parce que je me suis rendue
récemment comme un certain nombre
d'entre vous tous parce que mon frère
est installé depuis 30 ans qui a
travaillé dans les trois provinces et
qu'il est aujourd'hui responsable de la
vaccination covit pour toute la province
sud
aujourd'hui je suis inquiet très inquiet
nous avons vu quelques semaines après le
deuxième référendum du 4 octobre dernier
la nouvelle calédonie s'embraser nous
avons assisté aussi à des scènes proche
de la guerre civile sur le dossier de
rachat de l'usiné val du sud
heureusement il n'ya pas eu de victimes
et nous le devons monsieur le ministre
avait une responsabilité en termes de
maintien de l'ordre et à la volonté
politique des acteurs de sortir par le
haut de ce dossier brûlant
mais je reste néanmoins préoccupés par
ce qui peut arriver maintenant
lors du deuxième référendum du 4 octobre
dernier
les bureaux de vote ont été des pris
d'assaut par des militants
indépendantistes drapeau identitaire
kanak à la main pour mieux influencer au
pire dissuader voire menacer certains
électeurs loyalistes il est clair au vu
des réactions qu'ils ont eu pendant le
conflit de l'usiné du sud que les
loyalistes ne vont pas plus subir en
silence ces actions hostiles de la part
de leurs adversaires
à quoi tout cela va-t-il nous mener que
se passera-t-il lorsqu'il y aura devant
le bureau de vote des militants de
chaque camp qui considéreront qu'ils
jouent leurs dernières cartouches
je pense que laisser se tenir un
référendum binaire dans la situation
actuelle tel qu'il est prévu dans
l'accord de nouméa
alors qu'on sait que la population est
divisée en deux et qu'on connaît le
caractère explosif de la nouvelle
calédonie
c'est prendre un risque majeur pour
l'avenir et figée de façon mortifère
les oppositions ethniques sociales et
politiques
monsieur le ministre certains pourraient
être tentés de simplement repousser la
date du troisième référendum au plus
tard c'est à dire en septembre 2022
considérant que les prochains
gouvernants traiteront ces sujets et que
la nouvelle calédonie ne sera pas dans
ce cas un risque majeur pour la campagne
électorale
là ce serait une erreur j'ai le
gouvernement décidé de maintenir la même
question que lors des deux premières
consultations et de fixer la date au
plus tard la campagne présidentielle
serait de fait instrumentalisés par les
deux camps et le moindre fait divers
impliquant une ethnie contre l'autre
serait utilisée pour servir sa cause
c'est un risque que vous ne pouvez pas
faire prendre à notre pays et la
nouvelle calédonie
je porte avec certains collègues la
conviction qu'une autre voie est
possible qu'à plusieurs reprises le pari
de l'intelligence a été gagné en
nouvelle calédonie en 1988 au moment des
accords de matignon ou encore improbable
a été trouvé en quelques jours grâce à
la volonté de michel rocard en 98 en
quelques semaines parce que les
responsables politiques locaux ont
considéré que les peler n'était pas
suffisamment refermée pour organiser un
nouveau référendum
plus récemment en mars de cette année
avec cet accord sur l'usiné du sud
auquel plus personne ne croyait cette
voile existe chacun nouvelle calédonie
le sait puisque indépendantistes et
loyalistes savent que l'accord de nouméa
leur impose de se retrouver pour
examiner la situation crée le lendemain
du troisième référendum
pourquoi attendre que les calédoniens se
déchire une troisième fois pour
rechercher cette solution il est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement déposé un
projet sur la table un projet qui
maintiendra le lien si particulier que
la france a construit depuis près de
deux siècles avec la nouvelle calédonie
un projet qui reconnaîtra l'identité
kanak et les autres identités qui
cohabitent en nouvelle calédonie un
projet qui prend en compte le fait que
les divisions de la nouvelle calédonie
sont à la fois géographiques ethniques
et politiques
les accords de matignon était basée sur
un partage du pouvoir entre les deux
légitimités qui vit en nouvelle
calédonie ce partage géographique et
politique a donné de province sur 3 aux
indépendantistes et a permis dix ans de
paix et de développement économique sans
précédent
c'est lorsque l'accord de nouméa a tenté
de gommer les différences et de
centraliser le pouvoir dans un
gouvernement collégial que les choses se
sont gâtées 17 gouvernement en fait deux
ans sans commentaire la raison est
simple les différends sont trop fortes
pour être fondue dans une seule
institution
la solution passera j'en suis convaincue
par l'acceptation et l'addition des
différences mais cette solution ce n'est
pas non responsable métropolitan qui
reconstruiront ce sont les responsables
politiques calédoniens et pour se
retrouver ils ont besoin ce faux encore
que le gouvernement prenne des
initiatives qu'ils demandent aux
indépendantistes ce qu'ils attendent
réellement de l'indépendance et aux
loyalistes
ce qu'ils veulent de la france et qu'ils
prennent le temps de rapprocher les
solutions avec la conviction qu'il ne
peut pas échouer
quand il ya une volonté il ya toujours
un chemin l'avenir d'un petit bout de la
france est entre vos mains sur le
ministre les calédoniens compte sur vous
je vous remercie
merci vos chers collègues je vais
maintenant donner la parole au président
bruno retailleau pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je suis
très heureux que nous ayons ce débat ce
débat a été demandé par mon groupe
il porte une double marque et ils
souhaitent adressé un double message
double marque d'abord la marque de nos
deux sénateurs calédonien mais je veux
saluer tout particulièrement
l'action de notre collègue pierre
frogier et ses contributions
la marque la marque aussi de notre
président du sénat dont chacun sait bien
ce investissement personnel au delà
notre institution à la résolution de la
question calédoniennes derrière cet
attachement de gérard larcher il y à
aussi l'attachement jamais démentie de
notre institution comme assembler des
territoires territoire métropolitain
mais aussi territoires ultramarins cette
double marque elle se complète d'un
double message d'abord un message
adressé à nos compatriotes de la
nouvelle calédonie dans leur indiquer
que leur avenir nous concerne leur
avenir est le nôtre que je ne conçois
pas le destin de la nouvelle calédonie
comme un destin différent du destin
français et l'autre message il vous est
adressée monsieur ministre et au delà de
votre personne au gouvernement voilà que
le processus d accord est en train de
s'achever
le gouvernement va devoir quitter une
posture si j'ose dire neutralité
d'arbitrage vous devez savoir que
l'heure des choix sans doute est arrivée
et avec l'heure des choix lors des
décisions dans cette décision
évidemment rien ne sera facile nous vous
accompagnons parce que cette question
nous n'en faisons pas une question
d'ordre partisane elle concerne tout
notre pays toutes les bonnes volontés
peau trouver une juste issue et nous
vous aiderons
à la trouver mais il faudra que le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
vous devez dessiner une perspective vous
donnez faire des choix et prendre des
décisions parce que l'heure est grave
l'heure est grave parce que c'est le
moment de tous les dangers un précédent
en intervenant a souligné les tensions
le retour d'ailleurs de la tentation de
la violence
on l'a vu au moment du deuxième
référendum
on l'a vu aussi au moment des
discussions autour de l' usine du sud de
nickel je salue d'ailleurs votre
investissement
l'investissement de l'état qui montre
bien que sans votre engagement sans
l'engagement détail n'y aura pas de
solution en nouvelle calédonie et puis
on le voit aussi que ce moment de tous
les dangers est arrivé parce qu'il ya
des multiples crises et je ne parle même
pas de la crise sanitaire qui
s'entrecroisent et qui peuvent se
potentialiser dangereusement une freak
une fracture géographique nord-sud
identitaire social économique une
fracture aussi institutionnels pour la
première fois depuis plus de 40 ans les
mouvements indépendantistes se sont
emparés de l'exécutif et ne parviennent
pas à désigner un président pour le
gouvernement il y a donc une crise
institutionnelle
nous devons regarder les choses en face
20 en trois ans après les accords de
nouméa
trente trois ans après les accords de
matignon ce processus de pacification de
réconciliation est en train de s'épuiser
et en s'épuisant le risque c'est de
créer un grand vide et dans ce grand
vide
le risque est que de vieux démons
peuvent s'y engouffrer
le démon notamment de la violence alors
que pouvons nous faire
que pouvons nous faire pour éviter que
dans ce vide créé par cette situation
historique créé notamment par cet
épuisement du processus de ces deux
accords que pour vous nous faire pour
écarter ses vieux démons
bien sûr faire le pari de la démocratie
le pari de la démocratie c'est le pari
du suffrage et sur les deux premiers
référendum à chaque fois nos
compatriotes néo calédoniens se sont
prononcés clairement ils ont exprimé un
choix qui était celui de deux destins
liés
le destin du caillou avec celui de la
france de la métropole sans aucune
ambiguïté je sais qu'aujourd'hui depuis
le mois d'avril les groupes
indépendantistes ont demandé
l'organisation d'un troisième référendum
et c'est leur droit et je ne l'ignorent
pas simplement
simplement je veux poser deux remarques
la première c'est que s'il devait y
avoir un référendum on n'attende pas le
dernier moment on n'attende pas la praye
présidentielle parce que carey devienne
le disait il ya quelques instants
ce serait une situation ou en tout cas
un calendrier propice à toutes les
instrumentalisations personne n'ya
intérêt s'il devait y avoir un troisième
référendum
ça doit être rapidement dès la rentrée
la deuxième remarque on le voit bien
pour reprendre d'ailleurs les propos de
pierre frogier
on voit bien que le référendum n'est pas
la solution certes nous devons respecter
la démocratie certes la démocratie c'est
celle du suffrage
le suffrage c'est la règle du nombre la
règle de l'arithmétique mais
l'arithmétique ne conduit pas note enfin
nécessairement à l'unité à la
pacification parce qu'il ya des effets
dante agonise à sion parce que les
indépendantistes resteront
indépendantiste parce que les loyalistes
resteront loyalistes et qu'aujourd'hui
on le voit bien de nouvelle calédonie se
font face alors comment sortir il faut
en sortir par le haut il faut sortir en
inventant un nouveau cadre un nouveau
compromis
mais ce nouveau compromis il ne se fera
pas sans trois conditions la première
c'est cet esprit qui a présidé aux
accords d'abord de matignon qui ont été
rappelés il ya quelques instants de
nouméa un esprit de respect de chacun
d'eux chaque identité culturelle de
chaque histoire un esprit de
réconciliation qui s'est incarné dans
cette poignée de main historique
d'ailleurs entre jean marie tjibaou et
jacques lafleur qui s'était aussi
incarné ici là d'où je parle
candy coupe les os et avait fait son
grand discours qui avait été ensuite
diffusée dans toutes les mairies toutes
les mairies de france de métropole
mais il faudra des hommes et des femmes
qu'ils sachent incarner cet esprit qu'il
soit
la hauteur du dépassement de ces
différentes origines le disent les
différentes identités
c'est la première condition la seconde
condition est là je vais être clair ce
sera un nouveau compromis institutionnel
jamais pierre frogier vous m'entendez
bien jamais pierre frogier n'a réclamé
une partition jamais nous avons nous
toujours été contre la partition
quantique ou kewell parlé dans son
discours de lutter contre le séparatisme
d'ailleurs c'était bien cela et nous qui
refusons la partition entre la nouvelle
calédonie et la france nous
n'accepterions pas non plus de déplacer
les frontières à l'intérieur du caillou
simplement nous ne voulons pas d'une
partition mais nous voulons pousser la
provincialisation et le grand mérite de
pire projet c'est qu'il a pris son
risque il a posé sur la table des
propositions et moi j'attends que chacun
fasse des propositions pour sortir de
l'ambiguïté
bien évidemment et puis la troisième
condition c'est vous monsieur le
ministre
à travers vous l'état parce que si on
doit pouvoir trouver un compromis ce ne
sera pas un compromis qui laisse les
deux nouvelle calédonie face à face
l'histoire a montré c'est la grande
leçon de l'histoire de la nouvelle
calédonie que sans l'état pas d'accord
de matignon pas plus accords de nouméa
vous le savez parfaitement parce que
vous êtes intéressé vous êtes investi
personnellement dans cette histoire
douloureuse
je sais je sais que la charrier tant de
tragédies individuelles et collectives
je le sais au moment où je parle et vous
le savez mais l'état doit certes on doit
sortir de sa neutralité
l'état n'est pas un observateur de l'onu
l'état ne peut pas être un spectateur
désengager et je sais que votre volonté
c'est de vous engager
c'est absolument nécessaire et vous
trouverez là encore si le président du
sénat notre assemblée
quelles que soient les groupes par
dix ans à vos côtés au côté de la
construction pierre gérard poadja d'une
d'un nouvel avenir pour la nouvelle
calédonie désormais la nouvelle
calédonie va devoir écrire une nouvelle
page de son histoire
je souhaite qu'elle écrive dans la
france avec la france parce que je ne
conçois pas la nouvelle calédonie en
dehors de la france parce que la france
ne serait pas totalement la france sans
nos compatriotes d'océanie et j'évoquais
tout à l'heure ce moment tous les
dangers faisons-en monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
faisons-en le moment de tous les
possibles et de tous les espoirs pour
nous mais surtout pour tous nos
compatriotes néo calédonien quelle que
soit leur origine
merci merci je suis président je vais
donner la parole maintenant le questeur
jean pierre schoeller
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste les
rébus lien la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues fidélité ce
mot est pour nous le mot le plus
important fidélité bien sûr à cette
poignée de main
il y avait tant de raisons pour qu'elle
n'eut pas lieu
fidélité à l'oeuvre de michel rocard à
l'oeuvre de lionel jospin et de tous
ceux sans lesquels il n'y aurait pas eu
des accords de matignon
je veux parler des politiques
je veux parler aussi de tous ceux qui se
sont mobilisés dans la société civile
intellectuels philosophique et
spirituelle pour arriver à cet accord
c'était quelque chose d'improbable d'un
possible presque
il y avait eu tant de haine le sang des
victimes n'avaient pas séché et pourtant
pourtant cela a lieu
et quand maudit quand on me dit
aujourd'hui qu'il y a des difficultés ce
qui s'est passé dans la province du sud
à propos du nickel toutes les
difficultés
mais à l'époque où cela a été signé il y
à 33 ans il y avait beaucoup plus de
difficultés c'était beaucoup plus
impossible que ça ne l'est aujourd'hui
pierre frogier nous avons respect pour
vous vraiment vous avez le sens du
dialogue mais nous ne pouvons pas
souscrire à ce que vous avez proposé
cette chose singulière un accord pour le
désaccord l'oxymore comme si c'était une
sorte mais vous connaissez tellement
mieux que nous ce pays que je parle avec
beaucoup de modestie soyez en sûrs comme
si c'était impossible aujourd'hui et
qu'il fallait se résigner j'ai entendu
ce qu'a dit bruno retailleau mais
franchement s'il y a plus de province
s'il n'y a plus de congrès et plus de
gouvernement qu'est ce que c'est où
va-t-on en dehors de la séparation du
consentement à ceux là qui n'est pas la
fidélité à ce qui a été fait parce que
j'ai évoqué au début et je crois qu'il
nous faut tout simplement agir dans la
loyauté
ce troisième référendum est prévu c'est
un engagement
il doit avoir lieu je ne sais pas le
bruno retailleau s'il y aura moins
d'instrumentalisation 6,7 avant les
présidentielles que si c'est après vous
savez je vais confiance à tous les
instrumentalisent ateurs pour être
toujours présent mais
il faut que cela ait lieu parce que
c'est l'engagement et après nous
souhaitons de tout coeur qu'il reste un
lien très fort quoi qu'il arrive soit la
calédonie restera tant la france et il y
aura plus d'autonomie sans doute de
nouveaux chemins a tracé soit il y aura
de toute façon des coopérations très
forte
les indépendantistes eux mêmes le
demande
vous savez j'ai été à l'île des pins là
où sont enterrés les femmes de la
commune de paris
c'est vrai cependant que victor hugo ici
même plaidé en vain pour la mystique il
n'est jamais arrivé de son vivant et là
dans cette paix au milieu de ses statuts
ancestrales comment ne pas penser qu'il
peut arriver en effet dans l'histoire
que le destin ne soit pas la haine la
guerre et la mort mais que continue de
se lever contre les forces du mal des
êtres humains qui trente trois ans après
suivent le même chemin je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant donner la parole au
ministre d outre-mer monsieur sébastien
le corps du jeune ministre vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président du sénat
mesdames et messieurs les les sénateurs
à mon tour de remercier le sénat le
groupe l'est républicain pour avoir
demandé l'organisation de ce débat et si
le président du sénat on est d'accord je
commencerai par quelques réflexions
peut-être plus personnelle ou intimes je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas
véritablement personnel temps
effectivement l'implication que je porte
à ce dossier
la fiction je porte pour un certain
nombre d'acteurs de ce territoire
m'amène à aussi devant vous à réagir un
certain nombre des propos qui ont été
tenus auparavant dans le cadre de cette
discussion générale puis bien sûr parce
que je suis membre du gouvernement et
que je représente l'état monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs vous rendre compte bien
légitimement de ce que nous avons
souhaité faire de ce que nous avons
accompli ces mois durant sur le dossier
dit calédonien surtout sur ce que nous
souhaitons faire dans les temps qui
viendront je remercie d'autant plus le
sénat parce que ça sera ma première
réflexion jamais le dossier n'a été dans
un moment aussi décisif le président
caennais re la rappeler et jamais il n'a
suscité autant d'indifférence à paris je
pense qu'il faut le dire une différence
globale de toutes les élites des médias
des différentes formations politiques
quelle qu'elle soit je parle avec
liberté il faut que malheureusement les
tensions apparaissent en nouvelle
calédonie comme nous l'avons connue sur
le dossier de l'usiné du sud pour que de
nouveau la nouvelle calédonie fait sa
réapparition dans le débat public
national ou en tout cas parisien et je
remercie le sénat de prendre ce temps
cet après midi 2
de réflexion et de et des changes pour
poser aussi la pensée et je crois que
l'ensemble des interventions même si on
voit déjà que certaines choses ne se
conjugue pas peut-être en tout point
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire mais
vient nourrir un débat de qualité sur un
dossier qui le méritent et sur laquelle
nous devons nous impliquer effectivement
loin de toutes tendances partisanes me
semble-t-il puisque il s'agit de la
parole aussi de la france sur ce dossier
et sa parole l'historique justement dans
cette océanie compliqué je pense qu'il
faut bien se garder d' y arriver avec
des idées simples parce que les choses
sont beaucoup plus complexe qu'il n'y
paraît et au fond la première des choses
en entendant les différents orateurs et
en écoutant à la fois si vous permettez
les présidents kaner la présidente
assassi et le président retailleau je
pense aussi que nous les responsables
politiques nationaux nous sommes à un
moment du dossier on doit se poser aussi
toutes les bonnes questions
c'est quoi un processus de
décolonisation encadrés par les nations
unies dans laquelle la france membre du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
quel est ce processus et quel est son
avenir
une question auquel on sera amené à
répondre à une question sur lequel le
sénat de la république sera amené à
abandonner à ceux à se prononcer ça a
été dit par les deux orateurs du groupe
socialiste pareil pour du côté des
loyalistes
je me garde bien de regarder l'histoire
de ce dossier mais dans le yaka fokon il
faut regarder aussi ce qui a été fait
ces 20 dernières années dans les
différentes révisions constitutionnelles
qui ont quand même on le disait avec le
ministre alain richard hier dans un
autre cercle a quand même suscité des
créations pour le moins original dans le
droit constitutionnel français le
présent retailleau d'ailleurs lui-même
avait voté contre sur une révision
constitutionnelle parce qu'au fond je le
dis peut-être davantage vers ceux qui
appellent à ce que l'on s'engage pour
que la nouvelle calédonie et reste dans
la république
jusqu'à quel point c'est une question
ouverte que je pose ici devant le sénat
de la république
jusqu'où faut-il aussi adapter le droit
et le modèle républicain pour que la
nouvelle calédonie reste française sur
une question pierre frogier souvent
d'ailleurs pause
dans des assemblées plus locale en
nouvelle calédonie et ça c'est une
question qui nous est posée à ain où le
législateur dans la chambre haute à
l'assemblée nationale au gouvernement
dire qu'il faut que ça reste français la
belle affaire
jusqu'à quel point faut-il aller dans
cette adaptation pour que cela est le
français parlent de séparatisme double
citoyenneté gel du corps électoral
discrimination aujourd'hui reconnue par
notre bloc de constitutionnalité
discrimination sur l'emploi tout cela
est souvent méconnu évidemment cela
tranche beaucoup avec d'autres débats
plus récent que vous avez pu voir dans
cet hémicycle donc c'est une réflexion
que je livre ne ferons pas l'économie de
ce débat
le législateur français ne fera pas
l'économie de ce double débat
disons-nous le clairement là aussi dans
cette océanie compliqué il faudra pas
venir avec des idées simples deuxième
intuition ou sentiment que j'ai depuis
que je suis investi dans ce dossier en
tant que mise et outre-mer en tout cas
ce qu'il faut pas enfermer la nouvelle
cabine ans ont passé ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut oublier ça veut pas dire
qu'ils peuvent pas faire le travail de
mémoire gérard déjà a démarré son propos
avec des démos très fort mais je me
méfie beaucoup de celles et ceux qui
agitent le spectre des années 80 comme
un programme parce que ce n'est pas du
tout ce qui se passe l'histoire beaucoup
plus riche est beaucoup plus complexe
que cela pourrait évidemment développer
plus avant ce propos mais je n'ai pas le
temps mais en tout cas le monde a changé
et pouvoir passer trois semaines avec
vous messieurs les sénateurs de la
nouvelle calédonie
j'ai trouvé la nouvelle calédonie déjà
changé depuis mon premier déplacement il
ya maintenant quelques années
et puis est ce que la nouvelle calédonie
est dans la même situation qu'en 1998 en
1988 la réponse est non est ce que le
cours du nickel est le même aujourd'hui
qu'ils ne l'étaient à l'époque promesses
essentiel d'un certain développant la
réponse est non est-ce que
l'organisation géographique de l'océanie
compris avec le grand voisin
chinois dans cette indo pacifique à
bouleverser le rapport de tous ses états
de l'océanie c'est une évidence
il faut le voir la question du
réchauffement climatique
autant de questions qui font que le
dossier comme on dit si bien ce dossier
calédonien bas il est plus tout à fait
quand même dans les mêmes circonstances
et dans l'est le même parfum la même eau
qu'en 1988 en 1998 je lis le journal
quand je vois des coutumiers qui bloque
une réunion politique du fln cas s il
faut mais connaître le dossier pour ne
pas comprendre aujourd'hui que
l'accoutumée les coutumiers autorité
reconnue dans la république 1 prend un
rôle et prend désormais une surface je
le dis de manière prudente différentes
dans le dos et donc ne regardons pas ce
dossier avec eux le seul rétroviseur si
je devais moi aussi allonger la liste
des conditions pour réussir tous
ensemble les enjeux autour de la
nouvelle calédonie il nous faut partager
les contraintes et en partage et
évidemment les différents éléments qui
font que tout cela change beaucoup et
changent très vite alors j'ai été nommé
au mois de juillet dernier
il me revient de vous rendre compte déjà
ce que nous avons cherché à faire depuis
le mois de juillet et les deux sénateurs
ont déjà eu l'occasion évidemment de me
contrôler sur place si j'ose dire dans
ce que nous avons souhaité faire et
c'est pour moi l'occasion de revenir sur
les différentes prises de parole qui qui
m'ont précédé il fallait déjà organiser
convenablement ce deuxième référendum le
ministre soeur a raison de rappeler qu'
il ya un accord et que l'état est
signataire de cet accord et que l'état
de tenir sa parole après une initiative
politique peut toujours émerger mais
jusqu'à preuve du contraire il ya un
droit positif avec une parole donnée et
que ce premier référendum devait être
organisé
il a été organisé par le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe que le deuxième
référendum devait être organisé aux
méthodes mois d'octobre dernier
il a été également organisées dans des
conditions qui sont inévitablement
difficile difficile déjà parce que
chaque référendum qui passe crée une
tension évidemment nouvelle ça a été dit
difficile aussi parce que
harper déjà et pierre frogier portes
pour la première fois un masque puisque
la nouvelle calédonie a été co vite free
comme on dit si bien en mauvais français
pendant là était à l'exception d'un mois
de confinement et a créé aussi une
relation particulière avec l'hexagone où
nous nous étions dans déconfinement
successifs et la nouvelle clé dans une
situation sanitaire complètement
différente
et puis bien sûr un niveau de tension
qui a monté ça a été rappelé par le
sénateur pierre médevielle évidemment
sur un certain nombre d'incidents que
nous avons connus devant les bureaux de
vote et sur lequel lors de mon
déplacement en nouvelle-calédonie j'ai
moi même saisi l'autorité judiciaire et
le parquet de nouméa et une enquête
judiciaire est toujours en cours dont je
tiens elle indiqué ici devant devant le
sénat parce que lorsque nous avons
cherché à faire je le dis parce que plus
personne ne le dit et elle retour de
l'état de droit
c'était adroit dans lequel au fond on
finit par oublier que la nouvelle
calédonie jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est la république et dans lequel les
lois de la république que vous votez
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs ont
vocation à s'appliquer y compris sur les
libertés de circulation y compris sur le
fait qu' on ne peut pas porter atteinte
à la sincérité du suffrage
et moi je tiens à rendre hommage aux
forces de l'ordre qui se sont
particulièrement exposées comme rarement
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs des
forces de l'ordre de notre république se
sont exposés sur le dossier de reprise
de l'usiné du sud sur lequel des
gendarmes
à peu de choses près ont failli perdre
la vie et donc je pense que là aussi on
attend souvent le gouvernement mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs sur une réponse
de fermeté
cette réponse de fermeté elle est là
moyennant quoi il ne faudrait pas grand
chose pour que la justice et l'autorité
judiciaire de notre république soient de
nouveau regardé comme une justice
coloniale
je cite là aussi ce que je peux lire
dans les gazettes je pense aussi que
pour faire société il faut aussi qu'on
soutienne les pouvoirs constitués en
tout cas l'autorité judiciaire constitué
sur le caillou et sur lequel on doit
réaffirmer l'état de droit parce que ça
fait partie de nos priorités que parfois
peut-être une forme de laxisme de
laisser aller
malheureusement être constatés et je
crois que là aussi il fallait le redire
devant vous évidemment j'ai aussi
cherché à reprendre un dialogue
multilatéral ça a été dit l'histoire
politique de ce dossier est une histoire
3 cela reste au fond une relation à
trois dans lequel quand l'état disparaît
il se trouve que les différents acteurs
politiques ont plus de mal pour échanger
et ce fameux format le pré ndour qui au
fond est un format de circonstances mais
une circonstance symbolique fait que au
mois d'octobre j'ai réussi à remettre
autour de la table un certain nombre
d'acteurs politiques ne s'était pas
adressé la parole pratiquement depuis un
an ou un an et demi pour échanger sur
l'avenir la nouvelle calédonie cela
dépasse largement le miz et outre-mer ça
pose la question et von retailleau
l'adie du rôle de l'état en nouvelle
calédonie parce que dans un processus de
décolonisation
lorsqu'il y à ce dossier de reprise de
l'usiné du sud
il ne faut pas s'étonner de voir par
exemple des demandes de nationalisation
de cette usine c'est à dire en clair là
où on veut que l'état se retire du
caillou on en appelle à l'état pour
venir prendre possession complètement
d'un outil de production
tout cela dit quelque chose de la
complexité et du regard que l'on a
vis-à-vis de l'état le président gontard
tout à l'heure à parler de protection de
l'environnement
vous avez toute une jeunesse
calédonienne aujourd'hui partisan du oui
comme partisan du non kanak ou non kanak
qui nous explique que le parc marin de
la mer de corail fait notre fierté qu'on
doit protéger les récifs coralliens et
c'est quelque chose de suffisamment
important pour que l'état s'en occupe
contrariant ici même la répartition des
compétences entre la république et les
institutions qu'elle est de nien donc la
notion même d'ailleurs de régalien est
une notion qui est complètement
réinterroger en ce moment nouvelle
calédonie et puis bien sûr ce dialogue
multilatéral il a été rompu par en tout
cas où il faut le dire nous avons perdu
du temps parce que ce dossier de reprise
de l'usiné du sud
s'est invitée dans le débat qu'elle est
de nier la réalité c'est que on a
beaucoup parlé de l'accord de nouméa est
un préalable à l'accord de nouméa
c'était l'accord de bercy
et c'était bien sûr et pierre frogier le
connais cet accord c'était bien sûr une
réflexion opérationnel on va dire ça
comme ça
poussé sur la ressource minière et sur
la question du nickel et d'ailleurs si
je puis me permettre de m'étonner devant
vous et bienveillance l'intitulé de ce
débat c'est l avenir institutionnel
économiques et sociales de la nouvelle
calédonie on n'a pratiquement pas parlé
du nickel et je le dis les cours du
nickel ou la promesse du nickel de 88 98
n'est absolument plus du tout celle de
2021 alors plus du tout on a parlé de
lusine du sud
permettez moi de dire devant le sénat
que l' usine la sln de nouméa donc comme
vous le savez l'état est actionnaire par
eramet ça intéresse directement la
représentation nationale est confronté à
des enjeux qui sont tout à fait
redoutable pour l'avenir du site
l'avenir de ses employés des familles de
ses employés
lusine du nord massif de koniambo cette
usine du nord et tous s'y confronter
dans cette province du nord à des
difficultés qui peuvent être redoutables
éventuellement dans les mois qui
viendront donc nous payons pas de nous à
la question institutionnelle
je serai un partenaire évidemment engagé
mais je répondrais bien souvent sur le
champ économique est là présente assez
s'il l'a fait aussi sur le champ social
parce que derrière il ya des populations
à qui on parle du oui et du non mais sur
lequel il ya des attentes qui sont
celles qu'on peut connaître dans nos
propres territoires
l'accès à la santé la violence faite aux
femmes sur lequel les chiffres en
nouvelle calédonie ne sont pas glorieux
l'accès à l'éducation l'accès à la
formation la protection de
l'environnement il faudrait pas que
depuis paris on ne traite que de la
question institutionnelle parce que on
créerait un bis
avec nos concitoyens qui eux dans leur
vie quotidienne se pose des questions
aussi sur la reprise des vols
internationaux sur le déconfinement de
l'économie touristique enfin tous ces
sujets mérite évidemment d'être
retraités jeu pourrait le cas échéant
bien sûr et revenir devant le sénat si
si vous le souhaitez alors pour quand
même parler de l'institutionnel parce
que c'est évidemment aussi ce qui nous
réunit
le troisième référendum est demandée je
les dis je le redis quand on est
gaulliste
on est attentif à la parole de l'état je
le crois donc formé le voeu que quelque
chose d'autre puisse exister c'est une
initiative politique mais soyons bien
précis dans ce que nous disons cela ne
peut pas écraser la parole donnée que
d'ailleurs le législateur a donné par
les révisions constitutionnelles
vous me permettrez aussi et ce n'est pas
une coquetterie dans ma bouche de
revenir sur cette distinction propre à
nos institutions entre l'état et le
gouvernement
l'état est neutre le gouvernement peut
ne pas l'être
l'état organise le scrutin comme il
organise des élections sénatoriales les
élections municipales
on ne va pas demander aux commissaires à
nouméa de commencer à faire campagne
pour le oui pour le non et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on fasse attention dans
les mots que nous employons est ce que
des parlementaires des formations
politiques des ministres peuvent
témoigner une préférence ou parler d'un
avenir politique en nouvelle calédonie
la réponse est oui naturellement oui
mille fois oui
est ce que l'état dans ses fondamentaux
lui doivent sortir de la posture de
neutralité qui posture dans le mot est
un mauvais mot parce qu'il est écrit
dans l'accord de nouméa qu'un certain
nombre d'entre vous d'ailleurs on ont
ratifié par votre vote dans la loi
constitutionnelle
donc on ne peut pas demander j'étais un
peu surpris parfois notamment lors des
séances de questions au gouvernement
du jour au lendemain demandé à l'état de
sortir sa neutralité nom est ce que le
gouvernement de la république peut
s'engager davantage
où peut dire les choses la réponse est
oui et ça je les dis d'ailleurs sur
place
mais quand jean castex premier ministre
en répondant à une question au
gouvernement de philippe bas ici même
dans cet hémicycle a témoigné à titre
personnel de sa préférence
personne ne l'a relevé
pourtant le chef du gouvernement a déjà
indiqué une préférence et je vous
renvoie au discours du président de la
république au théâtre de nouméa lors de
sa visite présidentielle sur lequel le
chef de l'état pour le coup plus que le
gouvernement chef de l'exécutif a
indiqué très clairement une préférence
le vrai sujet il est autrement plus
redoutable c'est pourquoi l'écart entre
le oui et le non est un écart aussi
réduit alors si vous pensez que votre
serviteur en faisant campagne on peut
changer de manière aussi importante les
choses vous me prêtez bien trop de
pouvoir et on n'attend pas de nous
autres depuis paris de faire campagne
la campagne elle se elle se nouent sur
le terrain en tout cas je pense qu'on
peut et je vais y venir essayer de
sortir de ce binaire mais la parole
donné la parole donnée de l'état des
deux chambres
dans le cadre de la révision
constitutionnelle sur le fait que
l'accord de nouméa doit aller jusqu'à
son terme est une parole qui a été
donnée que nous pouvons pas retirée mais
chemin faisant et c'est un dossier dans
lequel il faut être subtil me
semble-t-il la corne nommé arrive à son
terme et ça a été dit par certains
orateurs
est ce que le moment est venu de
commencer à mettre plein d'idées sur la
table pour réfléchir je crois que c'est
le président caennais revers qu'il a dit
c'est compatible d'emmener l'accord de
nouméa jusqu'à son terme tout en mettant
en même temps sur la table des
propositions de réflexion sur l'avenir
la nouvelle calédonie c'est ce qu'on va
chercher à faire notamment avec cette
invitation pour les forces politiques
calédoniennes à venir
à la fin du mois de mai non seulement à
la rencontre du gouvernement mais aussi
des parlementaires
ce que vous connaissez et s'était
rappelée par le président du groupe et
l'air l'attachement personnel du
président du sénat à ce dossier dans
lequel il a des relations
je me permets de parler en son nom s'il
me le permets 30 secondes mais des
relations riches autant avec des
partisans du non qu'avec des partisans
du oui et souvent je dis à mes
interlocuteurs que la parole du
gouvernement n'a de sens que si on
emmène également tout le parlement parce
que des questions aussi redoutable que
la citoyenneté de la nationalité
autant que le gouvernement peut toujours
avoir une opinion
tant que ça sera le parlement qui devra
décider une fille née et on l'a bien vu
avec les révisions constitutionnelles
des années fin des années 90 et 1 et
2000 que tout cela n'était pas un long
fleuve tranquille tranquille de riz
suffit de regarder le vote du groupe
l'est républicain à l'époque où je
n'étais pas là mais je m'en souviens
quand même malgré tout il n'y avait pas
d'évidence sur la question du corps
électoral et un certain nombre de
sénateurs se sont opposés à la révision
proposée par le président nicolas
sarkozy
là où d'autres sénateurs l'ont accepté
donc je crois que cette humilité nous
traverse sur ce dossier parce que elle
doit nous conduire à casser les
problèmes en petits morceaux et avancer
avec avec méthode
la méthode que je vous propose est que
j'ai proposé aux formations politiques
calédoniennes pour essayer de sortir un
peu d'un binaire oui non
la csu prioritairement de travailler sur
le oui et le non j'ai l'âge de mes
artères et au fond je m'étonne quand
même que depuis maintenant 25 ans on
traite et on débatte en comité des
signataires de quelques questions il
faut poser au référendum 20 ans quand
est-ce qu'il faut poser cette question
pendant 20 ans à qui faut-il la pause et
le corps électoral
et figurez vous qu'à aucun moment à
aucun moment pendant ses vingt ans donc
là ça emmène plusieurs gouvernements de
sensibilités politiques très différentes
on a travaillé sur le oui sur le nom
donc on a laissé dire oui un certain
nombre de choses et on a laissé dire oh
non un certain nombre d'autres choses et
quand j'ai été nommée rue oudinot jeu
naïvement je posais la question mais qui
a forcément à dossier quelque part dans
la république et dans les services de
l'état qui vient quand même nous
instruire et nous dire ce qui se passe
en cas d'indépendance et le cas échéant
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être juridiquement
encore plus compliqué qu'est ce qui se
passe en cas de 3e n'ont jamais jamais
personne n'avait imaginé qu'il fallait à
ce point travailler sur le oui sur le
nom parce que à force d'imaginer que cet
accord de nommer un accord qui donnait
du temps et bas de la vertu de donner du
temps au travers de
perdre du temps ou de vouloir en gagner
au sens noble du terme
eh bien nous sommes tombés dans ce
travers le travail du oui et du non j'y
crois beaucoup
nous allons mettre sur la table un
premier document que nous allons envoyer
adressé aux formations politiques
calédoniennes avant leur arrivée à paris
à la fin du mois de mai ce document je
me suis présent du sénat évidemment je
le transmettrai aux deux assemblées
parlementaires parce que je pense qu'il
faut que ce travail soit un travail de
coûts construction et de partage très en
amont
il donnera les effets les ai faits
intangibles du oui comme les ai faits
intangibles du nom ces effets qui font
que peu importe qui est ministre des
outre mer qui est présent la république
qui a la majorité à l'assemblée ou au
sénat
c'est intangible ça le oui en porte un
certain nombre de conséquences
cette choses doivent être dites et
écrites parce que on ne connaît pas non
plus beaucoup de consultation
référendaire dans lequel on entretient
un flou aussi important sur une question
aussi stratégique
il faut le dire pour le oui certains
effets seront redoutables les
spectaculaires pouvant d'ailleurs
entraîné aussi un choc de confiance dans
l'économie calédonienne sur les
questions financières sur les questions
monétaires sous les questions bancaires
on rentre dans le dur et donc il faudra
assumer aussi collectivement ce que veut
dire de mettre sur la table ses
implications du oui ses implications du
nom et puis ensuite lorsque les acteurs
qui allait devenir un second à paris on
mettra un deuxième document faire la
table ce sont des implications du oui
les implications du nom mais qui se font
l'objet d'une négociation parce que pour
réfléchir au jour d'après encore faut-il
déjà se mettre dans les conditions du
jour d'après pierre médevielle l'a
rappelé il ya cette jolie formule assez
angoissante à certains égards dans
l'accord de nouméa qui dit les
différentes parties se réuniront pour
examiner les effets ainsi créée c'est un
peu vague pour expliquer aux forces de
sécurité intérieure à l'autorité
judiciaire l'administration
pénitentiaire ce qui va se passer le
jour d'après en cas d'indépendance
on doit donc commencer à discuter très
sérieusement du oui alors certains
diront en faisant ce travail vous
préparer l'indépendance et le début de
bidule à sion parce que je l'entends du
localement vous êtes en train de faire
le brouillon alors après chacun y va des
accords d'evian à chacun sa référence
non moi je vous retourne les choses on
est à la fin de l'accord de nouméa
je ne peux pas en tant que mise et
outre-mer signé le décret portant
convocation des électeurs s'en expliquer
à ses électeurs
ce que veulent vraiment dire le oui ce
que veut vraiment dire le nom est-ce que
ça écrase pour autant une discussion
politique qu'on doit avoir à paris sur
le volet négociable de ce oui de ce nom
eh ben ça ça dépendra des différentes
formations politiques
est ce que une monnaie d'une kanaky
indépendante a vocation à s'adosser sur
l'euro le principe
non parce que ça peut faire l'objet
d'une négociation plus globale peut-être
c'est aussi simple que ça c'est une
mécanique qui redoutablement complexe je
vois le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères sous ça aussi des
implications importantes dans la zone
alors cela va nous amener à quatre
questions plus complexes
qu'est-ce que l'indépendance en 2021
est-ce que l'indépendance de 2021 c'est
celle qu'évoque et promeut jean marie
tjibaou
dans les années 80 une vraie question
quel projet l'a dit dans son propos
quelle est la définition la pleine
souveraineté
alors on en a une c'est celle que le
droit international nous donne mais
quand on discute avec les formations
politiques indépendantistes
on s'aperçoit que la notion de pleine
souveraineté n'est pas forcément
toujours dans la même acceptation et la
même définition des uns et des autres
c'est là où il faut prendre le temps de
discuter avec notamment l'union
calédonienne d'un côté et l'unis ou le
palika de l'autre sur lequel des
sensibilités s'expriment dans la
relation à la france et la troisième
question c'est évidemment c'est quoi la
relation que l'on veut avec la
république et le président a public il a
gravi des choses fortes
quant au théâtre de nouméa il parle de
ces nouvelles routes de la soie qui peut
emmener vers un nouvel impérialisme dans
le pacifique dit devant les commissaires
aux affaires étrangères c'est quand même
mettre aussi l'enjeu là où il se trouve
en ce moment donc c'est quoi cette
relation avec la france parfois vous
avez des indépendantistes
qui vous parle de la mère patrie ou du
sang versé dans des grands conflits
notamment pour la seconde guerre
mondiale tandis que certains loyalistes
m'ont dit sur place
c'est sébastien c'est avant tout un
passeport attention mon propos ne doit
pas être caricaturé ce n'est pas la
majorité du genre je dis juste que tout
cela beaucoup plus nuancé et que cela
mérite évidemment d'être d'être
travaillés plus enfin qu'est-ce qu'être
français en 2021
la question est le elle traumatisme
beaucoup de jeunes en nouvelle calédonie
enfin si on pousse la porte d'un collège
de vernon dans l'eure qu'on pose la
question à ces collégiens c'est quoi
être français en 2021 j'ai bien peur
aussi que la question soit tout aussi
redoutable
donc ces sujets doivent être abordés
avec beaucoup de patience et beaucoup de
temps vous avez tous noté que si des
accords ont été permis est possible en
88 ans 98 c'est parce que l'état était
là de ce que j'ai cru comprendre des
différents protagonistes
c'est aussi parce que nous avons su
faire preuve à l'époque de tempérance
d'écouté de dialogue et de compréhension
sur les aspirations les plus profondes
des différentes parties il faut donc
remettre le dossier dans son contexte
international
je les dis sur l'ado pacifique je le
rappelle et je leur note sur le
processus de décolonisation et voilà un
sujet qui peut intéresser la commission
des affaires étrangères du sénat nous
sommes membres des nations unies
c'est un processus encadrés par le ses
24 ces sujets ne sont pas sans incidence
sur d'autres territoires de la
république ultramarins ou non dans
lequel là aussi je pense qu'il faudra un
moment donné éclairer sur les
implications si le non l'emporté une
troisième fois est ce que le processus
d'autodétermination c'est important ça a
été dit par certains est d'ailleurs de
la vie de l'état la réponse est non le
troisième nom n'en porte pas pour autant
la fin de l'automne date heure en tout
cas du droit à l'autodétermination donc
voilà un sujet là aussi complexe qui
mettra d'être d'être largement traitée
et documenter les questions économiques
et sociales
je n'y reviens pas je note quand même
que le gouvernement vous proposera en
loi de finances
l'inscription d'une somme de 82 millions
d'euros pour aller en soutien aux
finances de la nouvelle calédonie du
gouvernement calédonien
ce sont des dépenses qui sont
essentiellement explicable par
évidemment la crise que vides parce que
pour que ces territoires puis cet
exemple que vides un certain nombre de
fermetures de frontières de 14 n ont été
mises en place et ont particulièrement
impacté les finances calédoniennes enfin
les parlementaires d'ailleurs se sont
mobilisés sur le sujet qu'ils en soient
remerciés dans un processus de
décolonisation que l'état a bondi de 81
2 millions d'euros le gouvernement
autonome en grande partie de la nouvelle
calédonie ce samedi aussi quelque chose
du moment dans lequel nous sommes dans
ce dans ce dossier en tout cas il faudra
leur dire les vaccins pardon mais
certain nombre d'entre vous m'ont
interpellé ou interpeller olivier
ferrand lors des questions au
gouvernement sur le sujet la nouvelle
calédonie à aucun moment on a manqué de
vaccins
la solidarité nationale c'est là aussi
largement exprimée avec des choix
importants qui ont été faits sur lequel
parfois on a oublié de rappeler que
lorsqu'il ya un coup dur la république
est là c'est quand même aussi une
réalité puisque oui heureusement mais
regardant l'histoire
regardons l'histoire regardons ce qui
s'est passé ces vingt dernières années
puisqu'on dit qu' il faut s'engager à
l'engagement du gouvernement sato pas
que des paroles ce sont aussi des actes
si dans les coups durs aussi qu'on
arrive à mesurer la fraternité
républicaine en tout cas nous l'avons
fait alors bien sûr et j'en terminerai
peut-être par là par trois points
rapides il ya la question du calendrier
ça a été dit par bruno retailleau
les accords sont claires un troisième
référendum peut être demandé six mois
après le second il a été demandé
il doit avoir lieu dans un délai de deux
ans maximum
après le second ce qui nous
donc au mois d'octobre 2022 cette
décision elle en revient au pouvoir
réglementaire sous forme de décret
portant convocation des électeurs donc
c'est donc le gouvernement qui doit
prendre cette décision
j'attends beaucoup de la rencontre que
nous allons avoir à la fin du mois de
mai j'essaie d'être cohérent et sans
langue de bois
monsieur le président retailleau d'un
côté je vois des indépendantistes qu'il
le demande très vite ce troisième
référendum
n'oubliez pas que ils ont la faculté de
le demander dans toute cette période
c'est à dire qu'ils auraient pu le
demander plus tard comme d'ailleurs ce
qui n'est pas interdit est autorisé
peuvent retirer la demande de référendum
maintenant et pourquoi pas la
réintroduire dans trois ou quatre ou six
mois ils ont parfaitement le droit
première lecture s'il a été demandée
aussi vite c'est que sûrement les
indépendantistes ont envie qu'ils aient
lieu vite en tout cas c'est une lecture
normande des choses simples mais je
crois efficace bon en tout cas nous les
services de l'état pour le coup nous
tenons prêts à pouvoir l'organiser
autant cette fin d'année 2021 qu'à la
fin de l'année 2022
techniquement nous ne tenons prêts à
pouvoir l'organiser dans les deux cas ça
va beaucoup dépendre évidemment des
échanges politiques à la fin du mois ça
va aussi dépendre de notre capacité
collective à éclairer le oui et le non
je ne serai pas assumer à référendum
précipiter dans lequel on n'est pas
forcément éclairer les implications du
oui et du non
donc tout ça va dépendre essentiellement
de la discussion politique que nous
allons avoir et je pense que tout le
monde viendra qu'à paris en tout cas
nous nous serons là si je dois rester
seul je resterai sol mais la main est
tendue et nous devons avancer sur ce
dossier
l'accord lui arrive à son terme et
personne ne comprendrait que nous ayons
laissé filer les choses et que nous nous
soyons désintéresser de là vient la
nouvelle calédonie donc c'est notre
engagement
la deuxième des choses parce que ce n'a
pas été cité c'est le travail essentiel
que nous avons
vis-à-vis de la société civile je sais
que parfois ces choses là sont
caricaturés mais la nouvelle calédonie
c'est un territoire particulièrement
jeunes dans lequel la prise de parole
d'un certain nombre n'est pas forcément
chose aisée ou chose facile et sur
lequel nous avons fait un travail
important et parce que aussi dans cette
affaire du corps électoral
ce n'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas
inscrit sur les listes électorales qu'on
a rien à dire et ce travail sur la
société civile c'était aussi pour nous
le moment dans lequel celles et ceux
aussi d'ailleurs les corps
intermédiaires l'université le patronat
les syndicats ont pu s'emparer un moment
donné de ces questions disant mais
qu'est ce que nous on souhaite faire et
je le dis pour notre sénateur de wallis
et futuna
c'est aussi une démarche dans lequel les
wallisiens et futuniens se sont
largement engagé parce que souvent ils
ont été les oubliés dans la question
calédonienne et voilà un autre le
troisième territoire notre territoire
français du pacifique sur lequel on doit
aussi s'intéresser aux communautés
évidemment wallisienne et futunienne qui
sont présentes à à nouméa donc ce
travail de la société civile un rendu
sera fait dans les jours qui viendront
je communiquerai là aussi aux deux
assemblées parlementaires parce qu'il
constituera une base de réflexion et des
changes sur l'avenir de la nouvelle
calédonie est enfin bien sûr il ya la
proposition de pierre frogier
alors je vais parler là aussi avec
beaucoup de franchise déjà merci parce
que bien heureux celles et ceux qui
prennent des risques dans ce dossier la
critique est facile l'art est difficile
j'en sais quelque chose et beaucoup de
gens nous explique qu'il ya qu'à faut
qu'on
mais il ya peu de gens qui se mettent
derrière un clavier ou qui prennent un
stylo et qui pose des idées par écrit
vous avez le dollar je me suis le
sénateur
vous êtes expérimenté vous avez
l'habitude de la vie politique
calédonienne de la vie de chacun le
double drapeau
les deux drapeaux constitue une avancée
majeure et va dans le sens de cet esprit
de l'accord de nouméa que vous avez
signé sur lequel vous avez rappelé la
tribune des limites liées au contexte
que moi même j'ai rappelé mais ces deux
drapeaux ont fait l'objet de caricatures
qui me semble injuste et déplacé je
tenais de le dire ici à la tribune du
sénat de propositions faut la mettre sur
la table maintenant alors déjà le fait
réagir parce qu'entre les différents
groupes politiques se disent des choses
enfin c'est une démocratie et puis on
aime la politique dans ce qu'elle a de
plus noble donc aussi il faut regarder
cette proposition dans le détail
moi je la mettrais sur la table lorsqu
on sera tous ensemble à la fin du mois
de mai et d'ailleurs je mettrai sur la
table toutes les bonnes propositions
toutes les propositions tout court bonne
ou mauvaise dès lors qu'elles auront
fait l'objet d'un travail parce qu'au
fond parfois ce qui monte dans ce
dossier c'est le travail et qu'à un
moment donné on peut pas dire faut
mettre un troisième projet sur la table
il faudrait sortir du binaire il
faudrait faire autrement
mais comment autrement et donc il faut
rentrer dans cette épreuve du réel
j'ai une proposition elle a des mérites
elle pose d'ailleurs une question
essentielle la question du répartition
des pouvoirs entre les institutions
calédoniennes ça c'est une question qui
doit nous intéresser quel que soit
l'issue
mon avis du processus référendaire
quand on tire sur votre fils elle elle
pose aussi la question de la fiscalité
ou la répartition des richesses elle
pose aussi des questions sur
l'organisation géographique on ne peut
pas le nier la nouvelle calédonie avec
le sentiment aussi que le sud pourrait
être un sud retranché bref elle pose
beaucoup de questions mais est ce qu'il
faut c'est frayer que ça pose des
questions je ne le pense pas parce que
pour qu'il y ait un dialogue
encore faut-il qu'il y ait des idées et
des idées malheureusement ces derniers
mois j'en ai pas beaucoup entendue et
donc en tout cas sachez que
en tant que ministre peut-être aussi un
peu en tant que sénateur je serai
toujours disponible pour travailler avec
l'ensemble des formations politiques du
sénat de l'assemblée nationale pour
faire avancer ce dossier
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]